welcome to this video this is a viewer
challenge again and don't be irritated
by this very low rating on 1800 this is
some due to my opponent only having
played like two or three games in this
rating pool um are in this sun and this
blitz rating mode however you may call
it um he's more like to a thousand one
hundred and five minutes so a very
decent opposition let's see we have the
Queenie to line of the Roy and I have
played d5 more active continuation not
being contact with d6 take a note of the
time at some incremental it's three
minutes base time and two second
increment I'm wondering about Bishop g5
here ok that didn't that didn't happen
what I don't like to do is to quickly
take on e4 as this wood releases b3
bishop and the rock on you 1 i'm trying
to play for c5 here and here we go
yeah it always quite quite funny to see
this wall of pawns if I've g5g 5v5 it's
quite quite nice but white has
harmonious development and this should
not be underestimated okay hmm should I
play before yeah we don't want to open
with the a farm
at the moment the night is already on g3
not only to anymore so it does not have
a good control over B 3 and C phone so
before okay I believe okay I sticking
some time
yeah that's always a very far-reaching
decision taking on d5 hmm interesting I
have I have more than one interesting
way but I think this should be fine
right f for the night has a good good
post on their fault and it's a ticking
c3 at the moment with BC BC 93 maybe I
should have taken first on c3 now that I
think of it but it shouldn't it
shouldn't be bad really night xe5 looks
look suicidal going into the south penn
at least i can take on c3 but i have
probably something better you know
neither for is so that's a that's a
dramatic move if i take now 23 years so
the idea
mmm let's see can also i can take here i
have many yeah but ok let's let's play
it play this a bit quicker if i take
care of this what I did taking attacking
the Queen yes you will play 23 and then
I thought why not just the smooth if it
takes now on d4 I'll play C 4 i'd have a
really good position the knight on d5
and where is it going with the Queen and
sir yeah you only have this kind of
unattractive unattractive square ok I'm
wondering about b3 and c3 him ok let's
let's not waste more time this should be
one I go see three people probably and
it probably needs to go here 34 if I
then place it 30 that's very cute
actually c3 Bishop b5 / 75 yeah 55 55
b.tech c3 Bishop c4 and the queen is
trapped can only save it with moves like
rock d3 which is not really great and
I'm threatening c2 now that's
interesting if it takes Knight c3 should
be excellent ok better be some
let's see take d 1 you probably take
eight
yeah the thing is it's not so clear I am
I really a group d 3 as track playable I
forgot actually that the night on b7 is
not is not protecting the pole anymore
hmm okay he's not it's not it's not
really attacking it it's very surprising
okay I'll quickly protect the bottom and
the porn
I really hoped for more when I when I
got into this this is not not so great
rhythm thirty-seven seconds I mean it's
it's it's good but three thought that
what would be would be much better be
sure before hmm this is helping night
before it's not great
I have don't have many pieces shooting
the king he really needs to move and
Highgarden to rather substantial lik
here is playing much much quicker than
it ended loops
yea the deep one no he's got a pass on
his own my pawn is more more advanced i
hope this the check this is really
really know why term resigned this was
more due to the time problems i already
in let him into the game again round
here i think black should be in
excellent shape maybe I made a mistake
after the capture that's really a
question computer wants to go Quincy
seven maybe yeah but it's a it's it's
okay yeah this is really not so great i
forgot really didn't recognize that the
night on b7 is not protecting v3 anymore
and down it's tricky I thought rook to
e3 and now taking a look-see eight is
excellent rook c8 protecting the the
night yeah very complicated stuff I mean
this is yeah it's probably okay for
black the pawn is more dangerous but
Germany here we are down to second so
it's a it's very difficult to play yet
yeah here black as I could have taken d5
this would have been much easier yeah
hard hard match alright thanks for
watching and I probably play a rematch